الى حد كبير عكست انشطه وارقام المصارف
الامريكيه الصغرى المحليه في بورصه
نيويورك مدى القلق من المستقبل وعدم
استقرار السوق المصرفيه بوعيده افلاس مصر
فاي سيليكون فاليتشر وقد شهدت معظم
المصارف الصغيره بدايه الاسبوع في بورصه
نيويورك تراجعات ملحوظه في قيمه اسهمها
لدى افتتاح التداول ومنها مصرف فرست
ولاحظ المراقبون ان الحكومه الامريكيه
بكافه مستوياتها تسعى بشكل فوري لطمانه
الاسواق وتهدئه المخاوف عبر ضخ الاموال
وتقديم الضمانات للشركات الصغرى
والمستهلكين قالت حاكمه ولايه نيويورك
التي اغلقت مصرف السجنشر انها تسعى
لاستقرار السوق المصرفيه
يتعين على المصارف ان تدرك ان القطاع
مستقر وهذا هو ان بامكاننا تدبير الامور
الصعبه قبل ان تسوء الاوضاع
البنوك فقدت
نسبه كبيره من قيمتها
من خلال انخفاض اسعار الاسهم اعتبارا من
يوم الخميس يعني الخميس والجمعه ثم اليوم
لان المخاوف كانت ان ما حدث في سيركون
فالي سيكون له
نظير في تلك البنوك بسبب يعني تشابه
السياسات الاستثماريه وهيكل الوداع في
الكثير منها اعتقد ان التطمينات الوارده
من
الاداره الامريكيه ربما تقلل المخاوف ولكن
هذا لا يعني انه لا يوجد مشاكل في
ثم جاءت ووعود الرئيس بايدن شخصيا الذي
اكد للمصارف والمستهلكين ان ودائعهم
مضمونه ويمكن للمواطنين الوصول اليها
ساطلب من الكونغرس ومسؤوليه القطاع
المصرفي التحرك كي لا يتكرر الامر مجددا
ونحمي الوظائف والشركات الصغرى وفي نهايه
المطاف على الامريكيين ان يعلموا ان قطاع
الانصاري فيه امن
السيف نبره الرئيس بايدن المتفائله
تقابلها نظره الخبراء التي تطالب باجراءات
فوريه لطمانه الاسواق والمستهلكين على حد
سواء ومن بين هذه الاجراءات التي يطالب
بها المراقبون عدم رفع سعر الفائده التي
كان يخطط لها الاحتياطي الامريكي وذلك
بهدف الحفاظ على قيمه السندات الامريكيه
في الاسواق المحليه والعالميه نصر حسين
الجزيره